- CHECK IT OUT, DUDE.
THIS IS MY GOD STATION.
C-DOUBLE-O-D, GOD.
- VERY LATINO.
- THAT SPELLED "GOOD."
- YEAH, I HEARD,
WHEN PEOPLE TRIP,
THEY, LIKE, TALK TO GOD
OR WHATEVER.
WONDER IF GOD'S A CHICK,
DUDE.
BIG OL' TITTIES!
- YEAH!
- BIG OL' GOD TITTIES!
- BLAH.
- YEAH.
- LIKE, ONES THAT YOU
MUST RESPECT.
- ABSOLUTELY.
- ALSO MADE A LIST OF QUESTIONS
SHE'S PROBABLY GONNA
WANT TO ASK ME.
- WELL, ADAM, HOW MANY GIRLS
HAVE YOU SLEPT WITH?
- WHOA! YOU THINK
YOU'RE GOD, BRO?
- HUH?
- YOU'RE NOT GOD, BRO!
YOU CAN'T ASK ME THAT.
- SORRY.
- I'VE HAD SEX WITH FIVE.
JUST KIDDING.
100, RIGHT?
[both laugh]
[softly] FIVE.
- YEAH, I'M JUST TRYING
TO SEE SOMETHING
WAY MORE REAL THAN GOD,
LIKE...A DRAGON.
THAT'D BE SWEET.
- OH, THAT'S BLASPHEMOUS.
I'M SORRY.
- OH! HEY, DERS, BUD!
HERE'S YOUR COLLAR.
- NO CAN DO, GUYS.
ALICE JUST BUZZED MY CELLY
AND WANTS ME TO JOIN HER
IN WEST COVINA
FOR A BUSINESS CONVENTION.
- THEN YOU EXPLAIN TO HER
THAT YOU CAN'T,
BECAUSE YOU'RE DOING ACID
WITH US, RIGHT?
- WE'RE DOING DRUGS, WE'RE DOING
A LOT OF DRUGS TOGETHER.
- GUYS...COME ON.
THIS IS KIND OF
A BIG DEAL FOR ME.
IT'S MY FIRST BUSINESS TRIP,
RIGHT?
I'M LIKE STEVE MARTIN
IN THAT JOHN CANDY MOVIE.
- I THOUGHT YOU WANTED
TO BE LIKE STEVE JOBS
AND DO A BUNCH OF ACID
WITH US.
- STEVE JOBS, RIGHT?
CREATED APPLE.
GREAT COMPANY.
BUT THEN HE LEFT
AND CREATED PIXAR,
WHICH IS WAY BETTER,
THEN HE CAME BACK TO APPLE,
MADE THAT WAY BETTER.
WE GOT iPADS, iPHONES,
ALL SORTS OF STUFF.
LET ME GO CREATE
MY PIXAR.
THEN I'LL COME BACK AND WE'LL
DROP iPHONES, OKAY?
- I HAVE NO IDEA WHAT
ANY OF THAT STUFF MEANT.
- NO.
- AM I PIXAR?
WE ARE DOING ACID TOGETHER,
DUDE!
[buzzing and screaming]
- [high-pitched screaming]
- OH! OH, GOD!
- OKAY, HELP ME OUT.
- OKAY, GET THIS OFF.
- HELP ME OUT.
- OKAY.
- WISH ME LUCK!
- WE ARE DOING ACID TOGETHER